[Applaudissements]
non mais est-ce que j'ai pas touché le
pont ferré le sondage tend à l'instant
j'étais chez moi j'ai passé un autre
truc c'est à dire que les gars sans
déconner il faut être hyper rôle où ces
genres bientôt ils vont faire une
émission à la et vous êtes complètement
marteau ce sont des collages bientôt sur
tf1 elle est déjà vous êtes complètement
marteau amy le bricolage c'est tous les
dimanches sur tf1 je pense à d'autres
trucs aussi son écho neige est proche
dans le trou est déjà un air très chaud
sur la cuisine et la cerise sur le
gâteau la tristesse tant d'économie et
j'adore away une émission sur les
dangers de la route
eh les gars le coup du lapin c'est tous
les dimanches sur terre
une mission sur la corruption dans la
police et et mon cul c'est du poulet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]